we have just witnessed the biggest live
television implosion of a presidential
candidate that I can recall ever seeing
and I've watched old debates that were
from before I was even born Donald Trump
just completely imploding seemingly at
the beginning of the debate sort of a
somber and depressed Donald Trump and
then it became very clear that he was
angry and he was uncomfortable and he
was angrily pacing behind Hillary
Clinton and he was saying things that
don't make any sense and as soon as the
debate opened with the question about
the [ __ ] grabbing leaked audio video
tape you knew Trump at some point was
going to talk about Bill Clinton and his
sexual encounters and he did and Hillary
Clinton as a seasoned debater did
absolutely fine and not taking the bait
and did very very well there but Donald
Trump completely imploded on that and I
mean just everything about this is
surreal Melania Trump wore a shirt that
is reportedly called the [ __ ] bow and
her there the campaign has put out a
statement saying she was wearing the
[ __ ] bow but it wasn't it wasn't any
kind of deliberate thing any kind of
statement that was being made absolutely
bizarre now just so I don't get accused
of just saying how fantastic Hillary did
because believe me I am no fan of many
of Hillary Clinton's ideas but she did
absolutely crush Trump I mean it was a
beating in this debate Trump strongest
moment was when he said to Hillary
Clinton hey why didn't you change the
tax loopholes that you're mad at me for
using you were a senator and you didn't
change those now she did eventually come
back and say I voted to change the
carried interest loophole i believe it
was or a different one and we'll get
into detail on the show about what what
that loophole is but i believe that that
was Donald Trump's strongest moment
looking at this from an objective point
of view now I already saw it's it's so
laughable but i'll take a look again The
Drudge Report instapoll when I looked
had this thing as eighty nine to eleven
a victory for for Donald Trump I just
want to look and see where it is now
yeah eighty-nine percent still there
there were Republicans on CNN afterwards
saying you know it was just incredible
how Donald Donald Trump just he did
amazing out there and I don't know if
that's a you know an eyesight problem
hearing problem total delusions or how
someone could watch this debate and come
away with that but I can't think of a
debate in which a candidate
self-destructed to this level Trump
numerous times seemingly childishly
complaining about supposed extra time
that Hillary Clinton was getting we got
the count right we this is measurable
you can't just afterwards say oh she got
all the time and I just got no time I
couldn't talk about my brilliant plan to
take care of all of the world's problems
because he actually had about one minute
more in speaking time than Hillary
Clinton Trump ended up with about 40
minutes and some change of speaking time
Hillary Clinton 3905 I believe she had
so after all Trump got more speaking
time and if I were Trump I'd be trying
to speak as little as possible because
of the disasters that came out of his
mouth every single time now I want to
prepare you especially as you don't with
the columbus day holiday coming up we're
going to be back in the studio on
tuesday will be looking at post debate
polling we will be looking at the [ __ ]
gate situation as I guess it's being
called who even cares what we call that
it's Trump embarrassing himself on a
world stage and proving that he cannot
be the president we're going to be
talking about this debate already on
Twitter on reddit on Facebook the
right-wingers are angry they're angry
with me they're angry with me merely for
pointing out that Donald Trump is
completely imploded and self-destruct
they are truly and really really angry
and you need to be prepared if you're on
social media that they recognize that
this is just not good kaylee mckenna nee
this this young woman who's been a big
trump supporter on CNN throughout not an
official surrogate that I can recall but
just a supporter of Trump she looked
white as a ghost right i mean there was
no amount
of makeup that they could put on her to
make her not be white as a ghost when
she was brought on to try to somehow
defend the Donald Trump [ __ ] comments
tonight when she was brought on she she
had to concoct some way in which this
was actually a good debate for Donald
Trump I said it yesterday in my
commentary I just don't know how Donald
Trump comes away winning this thing